john cena is making his return to the
ring to mark his 20th anniversary at wwe
john will be back on monday night raw on
the 27th yes and in other john cena news
he gave the surprise of a lifetime to a
very special fan over the weekend
ukrainian teenager misha who has down
syndrome fled marijuana after his
family's home was destroyed following
russia's invasion of ukraine uh to
motivate him on their journey to safety
misha's mom told him they were on their
way to find john cena he's so great he's
so good with fans and the day ever john
flew to the netherlands to meet misha
and his mom lyanna surprising him with
some wwe merch including a belt awesome
take a look and we will see you next
time
[Laughter]
i've heard many things about you
when i read about misha's story you know
it reached out to me not not just
miesha's story but uh the story of
miesha's mom as well
having three days off from work right at
the time when i read this story and
being an hour away by air it turned
immediately into we're going and that
means spending an afternoon building
blocks and eating cake
that's that's a special afternoon when
it comes to
to the new friends i was able to meet
[Music]
[Music]
consciously
this was
a wonderful adventure
[Music]
thank you for giving me strength
to be sure
now